hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Zoltan made evasion tactic
was why does he have such a bad rating
hmm I mean for his standards is really a
very very good Brits player usually is
slightly above me yes an interesting
legal point of the wide move order not
having played nine f3 ok wants to go
with a quick Bishop a six that
definitely make some sense hmm
interesting is there some way to prevent
that Queen a for that looks really
strange
because it doesn't make any sense if you
place some other set up and he has a
couple okay okay not a move I expected
by an interesting one I was more
thinking about the night with looping
like 97 Prine moves 98-96 come towards
e4 but be five is certainly interesting
the young so is before anything here or
a four maybe 85 maybe April I actually
has before I should have thought about
this a little bit but take before I can
take deform mmm-hmm that's not good I
have very stupidly played AAA for is
just a very stupid move
and my idea is to get the night to see
five yep good move now it be three
there's nighty form yeah i just have
weaknesses here this is the thing i have
weakened my position for no particular
reason here with this a4 move it's just
a pretty awful play at least those
nights do a decent job of defending
stuff okay a rube situ or looks III em
both both are just around the corner
absolutely dreadful position check
mighty form and it's super easy to play
for him
at least the night on a six is also not
particularly grade can I gunite a three
here is that something to be five
hmm maybe maybe I can somehow avoid an
immediate disaster I'm somehow covering
stuff
and is this London systems they are they
are tough to break down really are I
wonder if I should just I mean you can
go to see to this is this is really
absolutely annoying I go to e 2 nite f2
okay let's do that I cannot calculate
this properly anyway if I can like look
c2e2 whatever just have to go with it
and he will play looks into I think
don't see black playing a defensive move
here I mean rugae aid as a joke there so
um what's the deal I can't take it and
now I have nights now I don't have that
it's actually also threatening a medium
I should shouldn't forget that I hate to
play I hate to play g3 here in this
position this is luke t 2 and wow what a
bad position he also has 92 no mine
ok
the only thing is that night when a
six-year which really doesn't do much
back is checking me unfortunately not be
four is wrong on principle but
okay success nights assign more it
doesn't work that's one of those games
that you really absolutely hate you and
play badly you get a completely passive
position that absolutely just sucks yeah
check check 93 yes that's a funky idea
no and it's unfortunately winning maybe
this one to continue it's still not fun
37 seconds and my king is in constant
danger something like 92 is this is a
thing Chang can I get a hook trade know
he has this shoot night peace evide what
a joke Jack cannot take it okay yeah
it's got 96 and it's the only little
little chance okay I totally hate this
game it was so easy for like yeah it was
so easy now okay this is nothing much he
of course but a for it's just a
ridiculously bad move allowing this yeah
the computer doesn't really see it like
that but I totally hate this position
now he's got all the options and I have
I just have nothing and this was just
maybe rook c1 I mean I can defend better
but for a human player this is the
absolute worst yep check you just sit
there passively have no ideas whatever
whatsoever yeah computer wants to play
this and
this is ok but yeah the line that the
engine gift is actually ok but I have I
don't believe that this is Jennifer just
checks me here and check this ok I've
got rugby to now ok this isn't it's
important now maybe I can hold it i mean
this night is bad but just a completely
bad position and check as is this you
cannot hold this is simply simply not
going to work with this time this is the
interesting interesting thing here that
in this position f4 is not so great with
a knight on c6 it's a lot better because
now he gets this Bishop basic stuff
going now your black is very comfortable
right so this is probably not very much
to be recommended for white in this
particular situation to play this
because here you just have more
weaknesses than black hairs like
especially for ok well thanks for
watching